¿Cómo espera Vladimir Putin hacer frente
a las sanciones internacionales?
¿Tiene el presidente ruso algún plan para
ganar la guerra económica?
¿Con qué activos cuenta exactamente Rusia
para disputar esta batalla?
¿Por qué el rublo se desplomó tras la invasión
pero luego al poco tiempo recuperó prácticamente
todo su valor?
¿Quiere decir acaso esto que el Kremlin se
está saliendo con la suya?
Queridos amigos, amigas, en este vídeo os
vamos a responder a todas estas preguntas.
La guerra de Ucrania, la cruel y despiadada
invasión de Ucrania no solo está siendo
una enorme pesadilla en el campo de batalla,
también está teniendo un impacto económico
mucho mayor del esperado.
Y particularmente en el caso de la economía
rusa, nadie en Moscú imaginaba que las cosas
en 2022 fueran a ir tan mal.
Lo que se anunció como una operación especial
se ha terminado convirtiendo en una intensa
y pesada guerra con un gigantesco coste en
términos de vidas, equipos y recursos de
todo tipo.
Una guerra que también ha desatado una reacción
internacional de tal calibre que ha superado
cualquier plan de contingencia manejado por
el Kremlin.
En pocas semanas tras la invasión, Rusia
se convirtió en una especie de país paria
y aislado, con gran parte del espacio aéreo
mundial cerrado a cal y canto para sus aviones,
con las empresas internacionales huyendo despavoridas,
excluido en gran medida del sistema financiero
internacional y cargando con un montón de
restricciones comerciales.
Tan solo en Moscú son decenas y decenas de
miles de puestos de trabajo los que ahora
están en peligro por la salida de las empresas
multinacionales.
Y no lo decimos nosotros, lo dice el propio
Alcalde de la capital rusa.
Fijaos.
“Según nuestras estimaciones, unas 200.000
personas corren el riesgo de perder sus puestos
de trabajo”.
Sergey Sobyanin, Alcalde de MoscúTras desatarse
la tormenta de fuego en Ucrania el panorama
para la economía rusa se ha vuelto tenebroso.
A medida que las sanciones han ahogado las
importaciones, que muchas empresas rusas están
teniendo que reducir sus operaciones por falta
de suministros, que cientos de empresas occidentales
están abandonado el país y que miles de
rusos están perdido sus puestos de trabajo,
la economía rusa se está tambaleando.
Para que os hagáis una idea, según el propio
Banco Central de Rusia, el PIB de este país
se desplomará al menos un 8% en 2022, una
previsión que el Banco Europeo para la Reconstrucción
y el Desarrollo eleva hasta el 10%, el Banco
Mundial por encima del 11% y el Instituto
de Finanzas Internacionales hasta el 15%.
Hablamos en cualquier caso de la peor recesión
en Rusia desde principios de la década de
1990.
Y ojo porque hablamos tan sólo del primer
año.
A medio y largo plazo son muchos los analistas
que apuntan a que las cosas se pondrán aún
peor, mucho peor.
“Las mejores estimaciones que estoy viendo
salir ahora mismo sugieren que la economía
rusa va a recortarse a la mitad de lo que
era antes de esta invasión”.
Daleep Singh, Asesor Adjunto de Seguridad
Nacional de los Estados Unidos)
: “Habrá menos inversión, menos comercio
internacional, menos integración de Rusia
en las cadenas de valor mundiales, y esto
combinado con la gente que abandona Rusia
significa un menor crecimiento de la productividad
a largo plazo" Beata Javorcik, economista
jefe del BERD.
Ahora bien, retomemos las preguntas que nos
hacíamos al principio:
¿Cómo espera Vladimir Putin hacer frente
a las sanciones internacionales?
¿Qué plan tiene?
Pues bien, lo primero de todo es saber exactamente
cómo se encuentra actualmente Rusia y que
ha caracterizado la etapa de Putin al frente
del timón.
Atentos.
[Pero, un momento antes de continuar: Los
precios de la electricidad, el petróleo y
el gas están por las nubes y han batido récords
de 14 años por culpa en gran medida de la
falta de inversión.
Y bajo semejante contexto la invasión rusa
de Ucrania ha sido algo así como el remate.
Por eso, ha comenzado a extenderse una pregunta:
¿Podría el hidrógeno llegar a sustituir
al gas ruso?
¿Qué empresas y países están liderando
esta nueva revolución energética?
No te pierdas el vídeo que ha hecho Si lo
Hubiera Sabido, el canal de información financiera
de Mutuactivos con el que participamos.
Os dejamos el enlace en la descripción.]
Continuemos.
UN NUEVO ZAR PARA UN IMPERIO EN DECADENCIA
Os lo hemos contado en varios vídeos, aquí
en VisualPolitik, la caída de la Unión Soviética
y la transición a una economía de mercado
fue de todo menos un camino de rosas.
La mala gestión económica,la corrupción
galopante, las finanzas públicas casi quebradas
y por último una gigantesca crisis financiera
hicieron de los años 90 una década dramática
para Rusia.
Por ejemplo, entre 1990 y 1998, el PIB per
cápita real de los rusos se desplomó más
de un 40%.
Y eso que el punto de partida no era precisamente
para echar cohetes.
Pues bien, de semejante debacle surgió Vladimir
Putin.
Se convirtió en presidente en el año 2000
prometiendo poner en marcha un amplio proceso
de reformas para modernizar el país.
Empezando, por supuesto, por la economía.
Y eso fue exactamente lo que hizo.
Al poco de llegar al poder el gobierno de
Putin puso en marcha el llamado plan Graf,
una plan que buscaba atraer inversores
(En cierto modo el plan Gref fue todo un éxito.
Sí, la corrupción siguió por las nubes
pero las cosas en Rusia mejoraron sustancialmente.
El gobierno ruso impulsó la privatización
y la desregulación de amplios sectores de
la economía, se buscó atraer a los inversores
internacionales y se estableció un impuesto
fijo sobre la renta del 13%, un flat tax que
hizo que Putin ganará muchos puntos en la
comunidad económica internacional.
El caso es que las reformas junto con los
crecientes precios del crudo dispararon el
ingreso per cápita ruso desde los 2.000 dólares
hasta un máximo de 16.000 a comienzos de
la década del 2010.
Un despegue que, por supuesto, multiplicó
la popularidad de Putin dentro y fuera
de Rusia.)
si miramos la participación de Rusia en el
PIB mundial, la situación 20 años después
de hacerse con el poder había regresado al
punto de partida.
Sí, los rusos son hoy más ricos que en el
año 2000 pero no han mejorado más que lo
que ha mejorado el resto del mundo.
Y lo que es mucho peor: la economía rusa
cada vez está más dominada por grandes empresas
ineficientes y corruptas cuya actividad depende
fundamentalmente del favor del gobierno.
Esto es lo que explica, por ejemplo, que Rusia
básicamente sólo exporte materias primas.
Desde luego, todos, absolutamente todos hemos
podido ver el enorme impacto que tiene la
corrupción en la desastrosa actuación del
ejército ruso en Ucrania.
Sea como sea, el caso es que ahora con las
sanciones aprobadas contra este país tras
la invasión de Ucrania las cosas prometen
ponerse mucho pero que mucho peor.
Y cómo veis, no parece que Rusia llegue a
esta crucial batalla en su mejor momento.
La economía rusa está repleta de corrupción,
más allá de las materias primas sus empresas
son muy ineficientes y tanto el consumo como
la propia producción local dependen en gran
medida de suministros internacionales.
Hasta ahora quizás lo que mejor ha hecho
Putin ha sido mantener a raya el gasto y la
deuda pública.
Sobre todo, tras la invasión de Crimea, cuándo
el Kremlin entendió tras recibir las primeras
sanciones que tener unas cuentas públicas
saneadas y muchas reservas internacionales
era algo necesario para disputar la guerra
económica.
Y es que amigos, amigas en 2014 el gobierno
ruso comenzó a desarrollar un plan de contingencia
que ahora tiene que aplicarse por completo.
Un plan en él que juega un papel clave esta
mujer que véis en pantalla: Elvira Nabiullina.
El problema es que las reformas se terminaron
muy pronto.
Entre los años 2002 y 2008 los precios del
petróleo se multiplicaron prácticamente
por 4.
Esto hizo que el gobierno ruso tuviera tantos
recursos que seguir con las reformas ya no
fue algo urgente.
De hecho, más bien el fenómeno fue exactamente
el contrario: poco a poco la economía rusa
fue pivotando más y más en torno al Kremlin
al tiempo que la corrupción siguió por las
nubes y los nuevos planes de reformas que
se presentaron nunca llegaron a ponerse en
marcha.
Esto junto al hundimiento de los precios del
petróleo en 2014 y las sanciones tras la
invasión de Crimea hicieron que las cosas
se dieran la vuelta.
Fijaos en este gráfico:
Sí, vale lo se, no es la típica imagen de
un oligarca con cara de malo, pero esta mujer
encabeza la contraofensiva con la que Putin
quiere ganar o al menos resistir la guerra
económica que los aliados han lanzado contra
Rusia.
Atentos.
LA MANO DERECHA DE PUTIN EN LA ECONOMÍA RUSA
Ganar la guerra en Ucrania y evitar el colapso
económico.
Estos son los dos objetivos que se ha fijado
el gobierno ruso como prioridad absoluta.
Pues bien, Elvira Nabiullina, la gobernadora
del Banco Central de Rusia es uno de los actores
clave para conseguir el segundo objetivo.
(Nabiullina, que procede de los círculos
liberales de Rusia ha sido una de las manos
derechas de Putin desde que este se hizo con
los mandos del país.
Primero fue Viceministra de Desarrollo Económico
y Comercio.
En 2007 fue ascendida a Ministra de este mismo
campo hasta el 2012.
Luego ejerció como la asesora principal del
Presidente para asuntos económicos y desde
el 2013 ocupa el cargo de gobernadora del
Banco Central.)
Algo que, por cierto, hace con mucha más
autoridad de la que tienen la mayoría de
sus homólogos internacionales: Nabiullina
lo controla todo: las finanzas, la política
monetaria, los seguros, los fondos de inversión,
la banca, las reservas del gobierno…
En el terreno financiero es probablemente
la persona más importante de Rusia y también
la gerifalte rusa con mayor prestigio internacional.
Durante años su objetivo fue estabilizar
el rublo y combatir la inflación.
Algo que hizo con mano de hierro: llegó a
cerrar 500 bancos, elevó los tipos de interés
muy por encima de los cánones internacionales
y liberalizó el rublo para promover la integración
de Rusia en la economía internacional.
[Claro que también terminó alentando la
nacionalización de casi el 70% del sistema
bancario ruso.
Pero eso es otra historia.]
El caso es que ahora sus metas han cambiado
por completo:
“Durante años, el banco central hizo todo
lo posible para ayudar a Rusia a integrarse
aún más en la economía mundial.
Entonces, de repente, el 24 de febrero, tuvo
que hacer todo lo contrario.
Andrei Movchan, ex ejecutivo banco ruso y
actualmente financiero en Londres
Amigos, Putin la acaba de renovar para un
tercer mandato.
Ella es ahora la encargada de liderar la respuesta
económica de Rusia.
La pregunta es, ¿Qué ha hecho para preparar
a Rusia, qué está haciendo y qué pretende
hacer?
Atentos.
LA CONTRAOFENSIVA ECONÓMICA DEL KREMLIN
Podemos dividir la respuesta rusa en dos partes:
las medidas de corto plazo y la estrategia
para hacer que la economía rusa resista durante
los próximos meses y años si tal y como
parece el castigo se prolonga en el tiempo.
En esta línea desde 2014 lo primero que hizo
el gobierno ruso fue incrementar sus reservas
extranjeras, incrementar el peso de activos
como el Yuan chino y el oro y, posiblemente,
esconder una buena parte de ellas.
Sí, sí lo habéis escuchado bien.
Se sospecha que el Banco Central de Rusia
ha escondido lejos del alcance de las sanciones
internacionales decenas de miles de millones
de dólares en cuentas offshore opacas.
e
Se habla de hasta 80.000 millones de dólares
en títulos deuda del gobierno de Estados
Unidos escondidos a través de empresas superpuestas
en lugares como las Islas Cayman o, incluso,
Bélgica, dónde tiene su sede Euroclear,
una de las compañías de custodia de activos
más importantes del mundo.
También se especula con que el Banco Central
de Rusia ha posiciones acumular en sus propias
bóvedas unos 30,000 millones de dólares
en efectivo.
El caso es que esto le podría dar cierto
oxígeno al gobierno ruso para seguir operando
en el mercado internacional.
Por ejemplo, podrían autocomprarse la deuda
externa de Rusia por una fracción de su valor
o pagar importaciones o inversiones críticas.
Luego, por otra parte, nada más aprobarse
las sanciones internacionales el banco central
ruso respondió con un paquete de emergencia
que incluyó una subida de tipos hasta el
20% - más tarde fijados en el 17% - y la
imposición de fuertes controles de capitales.
Por ejemplo, se limitaron los retiros de las
cuentas bancarias en divisa extranjera, se
estableció un impuesto e incluso para algunos
casos la prohibición temporal a la compra
de moneda extranjera y se obligó a las empresas
exportadoras a repatriar y convertir a rublos
el 80% de sus ingresos en el extranjero.
También se prohibió a los inversores extranjeros
liquidar sus posiciones en la bolsa de Moscú
o recibir el pago de dividendos o intereses.
Incluso, el 9 de marzo el gobierno suprimió
el impuesto sobre la compra de metales preciosos.
Si los rusos querían proteger sus ahorros
y no se fiaban del rublo, que compraran oro
en el mercado local en lugar de dólares,
libras o euros.
Según Sberbank, la demanda de oro se cuadriplicó
durante las primeras semanas de marzo.
El objetivo de todas estas medidas era frenar
a toda costa la huída de capitales y el hundimiento
del rublo.
Algo que temporalmente la señora Nabiullina
consiguió, aunque el precio fuera hacer del
rublo una moneda intervenida y prácticamente
inútil en el panorama internacional.
En cualquier caso son estos controles de capital
junto al desplome de las importaciones lo
que explica que el Rublo se disparará durante
el mes de marzo hasta recuperar su valor previo
a la invasión.
[Claro, que si tienes una moneda tan intervenida
pues tampoco tiene mucho mérito y desde luego
no impide el resto de efectos sobre la economía
local.]
Por ejemplo, dejar de importar componentes
reduce la demanda de dólares pero puede suponer
que muchas empresas locales se vengan abajo.
Pensad que el rublo de la Unión Soviética
- que no valía prácticamente para nada - tenía
un tipo de cambio oficial de 0,6 rublos por
dólar.
De la misma forma que el peso argentino también
tiene un tipo de cambio oficial y luego otro
tipo de mercado muy distinto.
Sea como sea, estás son medidas urgentes
pensadas para el corto plazo.
La pregunta es, ¿Qué espera hacer Rusia
si esta situación se prolonga durante años?
Pues lo primero ha sido anunciar que en el
futuro exigirá que el pago de sus exportaciones
se de materias primas se haga en rublos al
tiempo que el Banco Central ha establecido
un precio fijo para las compras de oro.
5.000 rublos por gramo de oro.
La pregunta es, ¿Y todo esto para qué?
Pues veréis, cómo hacerse con rublos hoy
por hoy puede no resultar tan sencillo ni
deseable para los gobiernos y las grandes
multinacionales la idea es que estos terminen
pagando sus compras en oro.
El cual se intercambiaría en rublos al precio
fijado por el banco central.
No se trata, a pesar de lo que están diciendo
muchas medios, de volver al patrón oro porque
la moneda rusa no será convertible en ningún
caso, pero digamos que es una forma de fortalecer
el rublo, incrementar las reservas de oro
rusas y atacar el sistema de los petrodólares,
esto es la compra de petróleo utilizando
la divisa del Tio Sam.
Algo que se considera como uno de los cimientos
del valor del dólar y que países como China
también están intentando erosionar.
El problema es que al final Rusia puede terminar
vendiendo muchas menos materias primas y teniendo
muchas menos divisas extranjeras con las que
operar en el mercado internacional.
Luego, por otro lado, el gobierno ruso parece
estar preparando una estrategia para comprar
las acciones rusas y los activos en manos
de los inversores extranjeros, por supuesto
con un fuerte descuento.
La idea sería algo así como crear un grupo
de campeones nacionales, grandes empresas
que se hicieran prácticamente con todo.
[Vamos, potenciar aún más lo que ha sido
la estrategia de control económico que el
gobierno de Putin ha seguido en los últimos
años.]
También se está planteando que luego algunas
de estas empresas puedan cotizar en mercados
offshore donde puedan recaudar dinero de inversores
de países menos hostiles como China o el
Golfo Pérsico, sin que estos corran el riesgo
de sufrir sanciones.
Por último el Kremlin ya ha anunciado que
reforzará la política de sustitución de
importaciones apoyando con financiación barata
a las empresas nacionales al tiempo que confía
que países como China e India pueden terminar
siendo todo un salvavidas para su economía.
Incluso espera que las sanciones no vayan
mucho más allá o se den pronto la vuelta,
aunque sea parcialmente.
En Moscú entienden que el mundo no estará
dispuesto a prescindir de sus materias primas.
Pues bien, querida comunidad de VisualPolitik,
este es el plan de Putin:
Aislarse de las economías occidentales, fortalecer
su divisa con el oro, recuperar los activos
nacionales y confiar en que China, India y
otros países similares funcionen un salvavidas
suficiente como para capear la tormenta.
Claro que esto puede resultar más fácil
de decir que de hacer.
Hoy por hoy no parece nada fácil que el plan
de Putin pueda tener éxito.
Rusia está cada vez más aislada de la economía
mundial y tal y como ya vimos aquí, en VisualPolitik,
es posible que ni siquiera China venga a su
rescate.
“Solo sentiremos el impacto real cuándo
las líneas de producción se rompan.
La mayor parte de lo que se produce en Rusia
depende de componentes fabricados en Occidente.
[..] Y así sin estas piezas, el trabajo se
detendrá.
En las fábricas de automóviles, en la perforación
en alta mar, en la aviación, etc.
Natalia Zubarevich, economista y geógrafa
rusa)
Tampoco podemos decir que nos sorprenda.
Los planes de Putin en materia económica
llevan mucho tiempo sin funcionar.
En los últimos años la economía rusa ha
ido de mal en peor.
Desde su máximo de 16.000 dólares, el ingreso
per cápita ruso había caído hasta el entorno
de los 12.000 antes de la invasión de Ucrania.
Y ahora con las sanciones todo apunta a que
caerá muy por debajo de los 10.000 dólares.
Esto supondría una contracción de casi el
50% desde que el gobierno ruso dejó a un
lado las reformas y puso en marcha su agenda
más nacionalista - y despótica.
Y todo apunta a que los rusos van a pagar
muy caro la agresión contra Ucrania.
Sobre todo si los países europeos y el resto
de aliados comienzan a reducir las compras
de petróleo y gas ruso.
Si eso se produce y tenemos en cuenta lo dependiente
que es la economía rusa de ventas energéticas,
entonces, el colapso sería con mucha diferencia
el escenario más probable.
Digámoslo alto y claro: no hay plan que pueda
soportar un impacto semejante.
Pero, llegados hasta aquí turno para ti:
¿Crees que la economía rusa conseguirá
sortear las sanciones internacionales?
¿Puede la guerra económica desatada por
occidente llegar a tumbar al régimen de Putin?
¿Durarán las sanciones el tiempo suficiente?
¿Deben los países aliados incrementar su
castigo hacia Rusia?
Déjanos por aquí abajo tus comentarios.
Y ya sabés, si este vídeo te ha resultado
interesante no olvides darle a like y por
supuesto suscribirte a VisualPolitik.
Una vez más muchas gracias por estar ahí.
Un saludo y hasta la próxima.